[Music]
I had a daughter Mulan and when she was
eight last year she was doing a report
for school and she had some homework
about frogs and we were at this
restaurant and she said so basically
frogs lay eggs and the eggs turn into
tadpoles and tadpoles turn into frogs
and I said yeah you know I'm not really
up on my frog reproduction that much
it's the females I think that lay the
eggs and then the male's fertilize them
and then they become tadpoles and frogs
and she says why had only the females
have eggs and I said yeah and she goes
soon what's his fertilizing so I kind of
said oh it's this extra ingredient you
know that you need to create a new frog
from the mom and dad frog and she said
oh so is that true for humans too and I
thought okay here we go I didn't know
what happened so quick at eight I was
trying to remember all the guide books
and all I could remember was only answer
the question they're asking don't give
any more information so I said yes and
she said and where do where do human
women like where do women lay their eggs
and I said well funny you should ask
we have evolved to have our own pond we
have our very own pond inside our bodies
and we lay our eggs there we don't have
to worry about other eggs or anything
like that it's our own pond and that's
how it happens and she goes in how do
they get fertilized and I said well men
in their from their through their penis
they fertilize the eggs by the sperm
coming out and you go through the
woman's vagina and so we're just eating
and her jaw just drops and she goes mom
like where you go to the bathroom and I
said I know
[Applause]
how we evolved it does seem odd it is a
little bit like having a waste treatment
plant right next to an amusement park
bad Zoni but like what she goes put mom
I'm you but but men and women can't ever
see each other naked mom so how did that
ever happen and then I go well and then
I'm like put my Margaret Mead hat on
human males and females develop a
special bond and when they're much older
much much older than you and they have a
very special feeling then they can be
naked together and she said mom have you
done this before
and I said yes and she said but mom you
can't have kids because she knows I
adopted her and that I can't have kids
and I said yes and she said oh you don't
have to do that again and I said and
then she said but how does it happen
when a man and woman are together like
how do they know that's the time mom
does the man just say is now the time to
take off my pants and I said yes that is
exactly right exactly how it happens so
then we're driving home and she's
looking out the window and she goes mom
would have just tribulus are on the
street like a man and woman they just
started doing it would that ever happen
and I said oh no humans are so private
oh then she was what if there was like a
party and there was just like a whole
bunch of girls and a whole bunch of boys
and there's a bunch of men and women
they just started doing it mom would
that ever happen and I said oh no no not
how we do it then we got home and we see
the cat and she goes had it mom had a
cat's do it and I go oh it's the same
it's basically the same and that she got
all caught up in the legs but how would
their legs go mom I don't understand the
legs and I was like she was mom everyone
can't do this Plitt and I go I know but
the legs I'm from I'm like the lights
get worked out and she goes but I just
can't understand it so I go you know why
don't we go on the internet and maybe we
can see like on Wikipedia
so we go online and we put in caps
mating and unfortunately on YouTube
there's many caps mating videos and we
watch that I'm so thankful because she's
just like wow this is so amazing she was
what about dogs so we put in two Hawks
baby and you know we're watching it
she's totally absorbed then she goes mom
do you think they would have on the
internet any humans made it and then I
realized that I have taken my little
eight-year-olds hand and taken her right
into internet porn and I looked into
this trusting loving faith and I said oh
no that would never happen thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you